pas nous retrouvons maintenant en france
gall pour entre autres choses son
dernier album dont voici la photo en
noir et blanc le titre générique de cet
album c'est baba cas et c'est aussi le
titre d'une chanson qui figure dans
l'album bien sûr et baba carte c'est une
histoire alors on irait les chansons ce
sont toujours des histoires mais ceci
est une histoire vraie vous nous la
raconter et rapidement oui en deux
il vient au cours d'un voyage l'année
dernière en janvier dans un village une
maman m'a m'a donné son bébé vous avez
vraiment de m'adonner elle a fait le
geste l'avait dans les bras elle a fait
ce geste comme ça terrible et c'était
évidemment une femme très très très
pauvre est survenu à paris en lisant
j'allais réfléchir et finalement en
réfléchissant je pensais que c'était une
mauvaise idée de le déraciner de et de
l'enlever à cette mère qui avait l'air
de la doré donc l'idéal et était de
m'occuper de lui de loin comme ça mais
d'aider sa mère un petit fille le mât
mais j'ai un fils parce que email may
cry invendus et ton fils va bien
oui et sans cesser son prénom babacar ba
baca oui d'accord et là quel âge
maintenant c est bien la dernière fois
j'ai vu en janvier il avait très semoir
donc maintenant et il doit avoir quinze
mois alors nous disions au début de ce
journal que vous n'aviez pas enregistré
deux albums depuis trois ans les par
hasard sur les verts on ne venait pas
trouvé de paroliers aux deux musiciens
nous ont d'abord c'est une volonté
d'espacé comme ça les disques et les
spectacles et puis à cause de johnny
hallyday j'ai été repoussé de huit mois
puisque michel berger
fait de l'avant dernier disque et gianni
donc je l'envié son planning y avait
marqué johnny l1 france gall vous étiez
après samassa m'intéressait de suivre
cette rencontre en tous les cas cela dit
vous savez il ya d'autres compositeurs
je peux vous donner des nouvelles
pour moi il y en aura pas d'autre et
franchement je crois pas que je
travaillerai avec quelqu'un d'autre
il faudrait il faudrait être fou pour
pour quitter un auteur qui est la
personne qui vous connaît le plus au
monde sur c'est tellement rare on va
regarder cette cette chanson en images
vous allez retrouver france gall qui
parle de babacar ce n'est pas le vrai
mon équipe
ok
dès que la caution
et ma fille qui s'entêtent
cela
il
puis
une heure
partant car
oui
bamba k
vis à vis tonga
c'est pas
ja
j'ajoute que l'auteur compositeur michel
berger a fait également office de
réalisateurs tant que vous l'aviez sous
la main vous l'avez demandé également de
réaliser cette chanson en images c'est
pas mal ben c'est à dire que oui
celle-là musée de le faire parce que
parce que c'était une chanson à lui qui
voulait que les images balance comme ça
et puis en plus c'était une histoire qui
le concerne est donc très bien alors je
rappelle que c'est ça oui bon très bien
voulait dire autre chose ils n'auront
pas dit comment je vais dire simplement
que j'avais lu partout que votre public
et bien se renouveler
vous avez trouvé d'un jeune public qui
vous connaissais pas et je trouve que
c'est ça finalement là la chance d'un
artiste ça d'avoir des gens qui ne l'ont
pas entendu dans les années 60 comme
nous étions petits tous les deux c'est
vrai que je crois que les gens qui
achètent ministre maintenant n'était
pratiquement pas nés quand j'ai commencé
à faire ce métier c'est tout à fait vrai
bon mais je suis content voilà merci de
votre visite
et puis bonne route pour pour cet album
et pour d'autres choses merci beaucoup à
bientôt apprécia et moi même nous vous
retrouvons